>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Good morning and
welcome one and all
to the 10th Annual
National Book Festival
[ Applause ]
>> We're thrilled to be celebrating
this milestone-- excuse me--
which we're calling a decade of
words of wonder, and we're delighted
to have all of you here celebrating
it with us, and I expect many
of you have been here for
several of the festivals before.
It gives me extraordinary pleasure
this morning to introduce the person
who was instrumental
in bringing this unique
and amazing event to all of us.
I'm, of course, referring to
Laura Bush who was First Lady--
excuse me-- brought the concept
of the National Book Festival
to Washington from her
home state of Texas
where she had conducted
it with great [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
>> She co-hosted the National Book
Festival throughout her years here
on Pennsylvania Avenue.
She's a former librarian,
a champion of literacy.
[ Applause ]
>> She's a teacher.
She's an author of multiple
books including her latest,
Spoken from the Heart.
Madam, former First Lady, you
speak to the heart of all of us.
She'll do a reading from her
book, then take questions.
Microphones are on either side.
Please keep your questions
brief and on point.
She's honors us by taking a time
out from an extraordinarily
busy schedule continuing,
involving her United Nations
role, her role with UNESCO,
her championship of reading
and many other good causes.
Ladies and gentlemen, please join me
in welcoming the woman I've
been able to call, I think,
with full force and with genuine
conviction, Reader-in-Chief
of the United States of America.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you all.
Thank you so much.
Thank you very much Dr. Bellington.
Thank you for all your good work.
Thank you for being
such a great partner
for the National Book Festival.
And thank you for continuing to
build this National Book Festival.
This is the 10th National
Book Festival which I think is
so terrific and I can see
looking around this tent and all
around the festival that it's
hugely popular with people
from all over our country.
So thank you all for coming and
thank you for the warm welcome.
I especially wanna thank David
Rubenstein, who is sitting here
on the front row, for your generous
gift to the Library of Congress
which will ensure that the
book festival will continue.
Thank you very much David.
[ Applause ]
>> I love the National Book
Festival and I'm very happy
to be here this year as an author.
I spent most of my life
surrounded by books.
I was an avid reader as a child.
My mother and I were
regular fixtures
at the Midland County Public Library
which was a magical place not only
because it house thousands of books
but because it was in a basement
which was a very exotic
place for west Texas.
Going to the library was the only
time I ever got to go underground.
I continued my love of
books through college,
through elementary school
teaching in Dallas and Houston,
through graduate school
and library science,
and then as a public
librarian in Houston
and a school librarian in Austin.
I made a career out
of my love for books.
And to help spread that love,
I helped to found the
Texas Book Festival
and then the National Book Festival.
But while I love reading, I never
thought I would write a book,
certainly, not one about myself.
But as George's eight years
in office drew to a close,
publishers began calling, asking
me when I was gonna write a memoir
and I realized that there was,
in fact, a lot I wanted to say.
Our years in Washington, the first
decade of the new century were
as consequential as almost
any other time in our history.
We lived through the most
vicious attack on our homeland
in the history of our nation.
I was on Capitol Hill on the morning
of September 11 and in a minute,
I'm gonna read you
something about that.
George and I cried with the
grieving families and we prayed
with the nation and we never forgot
that day for the rest of his time
in office, and we'll never forget
it for the rest of our lives.
I met so many of the brave
men and women who volunteered
to defend our country and
who risk and give their lives
so that the rest of us might--
may never know terror again.
And I've met the Voices for Freedom
like the former Czech president,
Vaclav Havel, the great
intellectual and playwright,
who for years was imprisoned by
the communist, but who never gave
up his hopes for freedom.
When the Iron Curtain fell, he
stepped up to lead his country
and he's still speaking now
on behalf of the oppressed.
I met the Dalai Lama from Tibet and
female candidates for parliament
in Kuwait who ran for office
in 2006, the first year
that women there were
granted the right to vote.
And I met women in Afghanistan
who under the Taliban could
not leave their houses along,
who could not get an education,
who would have their fingernails
pulled off if they so much
as wore a coat, a fingernail polish.
Now, their lives are changing.
In my book, I wanted to give voice
to all of these remarkable people
and to share these
experiences with others.
And I wanted to remember the many
wonderful people I met here at home,
the volunteers from the Red
Cross and the Baptist men
who drove all night to the
storm-ravaged gulf coast
after Katrina to cook meals for
those in need and who stayed
for months helping the
people there rebuild,
or the brave Coast Guard volunteers
who rescued some 30,000 people
stranded after the hurricane struck.
I wanted to tell of the days I spent
with the young men in our cities
and towns, many of whom were
ex-gang members and who were trying
to turn their lives around.
I was never prouder than when,
as part of my own helping
America's youth initiative,
I was able to welcome a group
of ex-gang members from L.A.
to the White House, the same house
where we hosted the Queen of England
and the Pope on his birthday.
The more I thought about
it, the more I realized
that I had some great
stories to tell even
about the great Easter egg caper
at the 2006 Easter Egg Roll where--
well, if you wanna know
what happened in that story,
I think I'll let you wait
and read it in my book.
I had so many wonderful
memories to share,
memories about the White House,
stories about our life there
and about our families.
And of course, many of my happiest
and most enduring memories are
of the National Book Festival.
I remember something from each
of the eight festivals I attended
during our time at the White House.
I remembered talking with
some of my favorite authors
with hosting Ludmila Putin
at the 2nd Book Festival,
with the National Basketball
Association players
who are our partners, the
beautiful gala dinners,
the wonderful authors
coffees at the White House
on the Saturday mornings, and so
many more happy, happy memories.
But I especially recall that
first National Book Festival,
September 8, 2001.
It was a magnificent day, sunny
with a beautiful blue sky,
just the kind of weather
we had hoped from.
Friends had come from around
the country to stay with George
and me at the White House.
Over 40 friends came from Austin
all who had worked with me
on the Texas Book Festival.
I remember how patiently the
festival goers had waited in line
to meet their favorite authors.
That first festival was everything
we had hoped for and more.
Three days later, our world changed.
And since we're here in the
history tent, I thought I'd read
from my book a little bit that
day that changed our world.
[ Pause ]
>> Tuesday morning, September
11, was sunny and warm,
the sky brilliant cerulean blue.
My friends who had come
for the National Book
Festival had all flown home
and even George was gone in
Florida for a school visit.
George H. W. Bush and Bar had spent
the night buy they'd already left
on a 7 a.m. plane to
catch an early flight.
>> And I had what I
considered a big day planned.
I was set to arrive
at the Capitol at 9:15
to brief the Senate
Education Committee chaired
by Edward M. Kennedy on the findings
of early childhood development
conference that I'd held in July.
In the afternoon, we were
hosting the entire Congress
and their families for the
annual Congressional Picnic.
The south lawn at the White
House was already covered
with picnic tables awaiting
their fluttering cloths.
And Tom Perrini from
Buffalo Gap, Texas,
was setting up his chuckwagons.
Our entertainment would
old-fashioned square dancing
and Texas swing music by Ray Benson
and his classic band,
Asleep at the Wheel.
I finished dressing in silence,
going over my statement
again in my mind.
I was very nervous about
appearing before a Senate committee
and having news cameras
trained on me.
Had the TV been turned on, I might
have heard the first fleeting report
of a plane hitting the north
tower of the World Trade Center.
Instead, it was the head of my
Secret Service detail Ron Sprinkle
who leaned over and
whispered the news in my ear
as I entered the car a few
minutes after 9 a.m. Andi Ball,
my chief of staff at
the White House,
Domestic Policy Adviser Margaret
Spellings, and I speculated
on what could have happened.
A small plane maybe, a
Cessna, running into one
of those massive towers on this
beautiful September morning.
We were driving at
Pennsylvania Avenue when word came
that the south tower had been hit.
The car fell silent.
We sat in mute disbelief.
One claim might be
a strange accident.
Two planes were clearly an attack.
I thought about George and wondered
if the Secret Service had already
hustled him to the motorcade
and begun the race to Air
Force One to return home.
Two minutes later, at 9:16 a.m.,
we pulled up to the entrance
of the Russell Building.
In the time it had taken to
drive the less than two minutes
between the White-- two
miles between the White House
and the Capitol, the world
as I knew it had changed.
Senator Kennedy was
waiting to greet me.
We both knew when we met
that the towers had been hit.
And without a word being spoken,
we knew that there would be
no briefing that morning.
Together, we walked the
short distance to his office.
He began by presenting me
with a limited-edition print.
It was vase of bright daffodils, a
copy of a painting he had created
for his wife Victoria and given
to her on their wedding day.
The print was inscribed to me
and dated September 11, 2001.
An old television was turned on in
the corner of the room and I glanced
over to see the plumes of smoke
billowing from the twin towers.
Senator Kennedy kept his
eyes averted from the screen.
Instead, he led me on a
tour of his office pointing
out various pictures,
furniture, pieces of memorabilia,
even a framed note that his brother
Jack had sent to their mother
when he was a child in which he
wrote, "Teddy is getting fat."
The senator who would outlive
all his brothers by more
than 40 years laughed at the
note at he showed it to me,
still finding it amusing.
All the while, I kept glancing over
at the glowing television screen.
My skin was starting to crawl.
I wanted to leave to
find out what was going
on to process what I was
seeing, but I felt trapped
in an endless cycle of pleasantries.
It did not occur to me to say,
"Senator Kennedy, what
about the towers?"
I simply followed his lead
and he may have feared
that if he actually--
if we actually began
to contemplate what had
happened in New York,
I might dissolve into tears.
Senator Judd Gregg of New
Hampshire, the ranking Republican
on the committee and one
of our very good friends,
Judd had played Al Gore for George
during mock debates at the ranch
that previous fall, arrived just
as I was completing the tour.
Senator Kennedy invited us to sit on
the couch as he continued chatting
about anything other than
the horrific images unfolding
on the tiny screen across the room.
I looked around his shoulder
but could see very little,
and I was still trying
to pay attention to him
and to the thread of
his conversation.
It seemed completely unreal sitting
in this elegant sunlit office
as an immense tragedy unfolded.
We sat as human beings driven by
smoke, flame, and searing heat,
jumped from the tops of the
twin towers to end their lives
and as firemen in full gear began
to climb up the tower's stairs.
I've often wondered
if the small talk
that morning was Ted
Kennedy's defense mechanism.
If after so much tragedy, the
combat death of his oldest brother
in World War II, the assassinations
of his brother Jack and Robert,
and the deaths of nephews including
John Jr., whose body he identified
when it was pulled from the cold,
dark waters off Martha's Vineyard.
If after all those things, he
simply could not look upon another
grievous tragedy.
About 9:45 after George had made
a brief statement to the nation
which we watched clustered around
a small television that was perched
on the receptionist desk,
Ted Kennedy, Judd Gregg,
and I walked out to tell reporters
that my briefing had been postponed.
I said you heard from the president
this morning and Senator Kennedy
and Senator Gregg, and I joined his
statement in saying that our hearts
and our prayers go out to the
victims of this act of terrorism
and that our support goes
to the rescue workers,
and all of our prayers are
with everyone there right now.
As I turned to exit,
Laurence McQuillan
of USA Today asked a
question, "Mrs. Bush, you know,
children are kind of
struck by all this.
Is there a message you
could tell to the nations?"
I didn't even wait for
him to finish but began,
"Parents need to reassure
their children everywhere
in our country that they are safe."
As we walked out of
the briefing room,
the cellphone of my advance
man, John Meyers, rang.
A friend told him that
CNN was reporting
that an airplane had
crashed into the Pentagon.
Within minutes, the
order given to evacuate--
an order would be given to evacuate
the White House and the Capitol.
The Secret Service had
decided to take me temporarily
to their headquarters located
in a nondescript federal
office building a few blocks
from the White House.
Following the Oklahoma City bombing,
their offices had been reinforced
to survive a large scale blast.
Outside our convoy windows,
the city streets were clogged
with people evacuating
their work places.
In the time I reached my
motorcade, Flight 93 had crashed
into a Pennsylvania
field in the west side
of the Pentagon had
begun to collapse.
In the intervening years,
Senator Judd Gregg and I,
and many others were
left to contemplate,
what if Flight 93 had not been
forced down by its passengers
into an empty field; what if shortly
after 10 a.m. it had
reached the Capitol dome?
Walking through the hallways
at the Secret Service building,
I saw a sign emblazoned with
the emergency number 911.
Had the terrorist thought
about our iconic number
when they picked this date
and planned an emergency
so overwhelming?
For awhile, I sat in this small
office area off the conference room
silently watching the
images on television.
I watched the replay
as the South Tower
of the World Trade Center word
was sound and then collapsed
into a silent gray plume,
offering my personal prayer to God
to receive the victims
with open arms.
The North Tower had
given way live in front
of my eyes sending some 1,500
souls and 110 stories of gypsum
and concrete buckling to the ground.
Inside Secret Service
headquarters, I asked my staff
to call their families and I called
my girls who had been whisked away
by Secret Service agents
to secure locations.
In Austin, Jenna had been awakened
by an agent pounding
on her dorm door.
In her room at Yale, Barbara had
heard another student sobbing
uncontrollably a few doors down.
Then I called my mother because I
wanted her to know that I was safe
and I wanted so much to
hear the sound of her voice.
Late in the afternoon, we got word
that the president was
returning to Washington.
At 6:30, we got in a Secret Service
caravan to drive to the White House.
I gazed out the window.
The city had taken on the cast
of an abandoned movie set.
The sun was shining, but
the streets were deserted.
We couldn't see a person
on the sidewalk
or any vehicles driving
on the street.
There was no sound at all except for
the roll of wheels over the ground.
By 7:30, we ran our way
up to the residence.
I have no memory of
having eaten dinner.
George may have eaten on the plane.
He tried to call the girls as soon
as we were upstairs but
couldn't reach them.
>> Barbara called back close
to 8 p.m. and then George left
to make remarks to the nation.
We did finally climb
into our own bed
that night exhausted
and emotionally drained.
Outside the doors of the residence,
the Secret Service details
stood in their usual post.
I fell asleep, but it
was a light, fitful rest
and I could feel George staring
into the darkness beside me.
Then I heard a man
screaming as he ran.
"Mr. President, Mr.
President, you've got to get up.
The White House is under attack."
We jumped up and I grabbed the robe
and stuck my feet into my slippers,
but I didn't stop to
put on my contacts.
George grabbed Barney
and I grabbed Kitty.
With Spot trailing behind, we
started walking down to the PEOC.
George had wanted to
take the elevator,
but the agents didn't think it was
safe and so we had to descend flight
after flight of stairs to the
state floor, then the ground floor
and below while I held George's hand
because I couldn't see anything.
My heart was pounding and all
I could do was count stairwell
landings, trying to
count off in my mind
to how many more floors
we had to go.
When we reached the
PEOC, I saw the outline
of a military aide unfolding
the ancient hideaway bed
and putting on some sheets.
At that moment, another
agent ran up to us and said,
"Mr. President, it's
one of our own."
The plane was one of ours.
For months afterwards
at night, in bed,
we'd hear the military jets
thundering over head traveling
so fast that the ground
below quivered and shook.
They'd make one pass and then three
or five minutes later make
another low-flying loop.
I'd fall asleep to the roar
of the fighters in the sky,
peering in my mind those
words, "One of our own."
There was a quiet security in
that and knowing that we slept
between the watchful
eyes of one of our own,
and then just a little
closing signets
from the 2nd Book Festival in 2002.
Many moments from that
day stayed with me.
But a particular note where the
closing remarks by the historian,
David McCullough, in which he
described John Adams' quest
for knowledge in quotes,
"The greatest gift
of all he was certain was the
gift of an inquiring mind."
McCullough quoted Adams
saying and I quote,
"I have the liberty
to think for myself."
And then David McCullough
added, "We face a foe today
who believes in enforced ignorance.
We don't."
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you all.
Thank you.
Now, we have time for questions.
We have a few minutes for questions.
I like your Charlotte's Web T-shirt.
>> Well, we've met.
You know I am the grandniece of E.
B. White who wrote Charlotte's Web.
>> Oh, really?
>> Yes.
>> Great.
>> And--
[ Applause ]
>> And two years ago when you--
and Jenna were signing your books,
we talked and you both
signed my book
and I do E. B. White presentations,
and I always bring your book
and show them and talk
about on your page
where you referenced
Charlotte's Web.
And I thank you so much
for that children's book.
It's wonderful, but this is
also a wonderful, wonderful book
and thank you for writing it.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
>> Thank you.
>> What was your exact
feeling when you found
out that you were attacked
by one of your own?
>> No. We weren't attacked
by one of our own.
We were covered by one of our own.
They were protecting us.
This was the plane
that I was talking
about where the military kept
that flew over Washington.
They were United States military.
So we were protected by them
and that gave me a great
feeling of security.
>> What was your favorite
part about being the host
of the National Book Festival?
>> Well, I love seeing so
many happy people here,
so many people that love to read.
And I think there's something
that book lovers all share.
And no matter what our
political views might be
or what our differences might be
of any kind, we all love books
and we all love reading, and we
especially appreciate that we have
so many tremendous American authors.
We have such a huge body
of literature to choose
from our own writers
and then, of course,
from writers around the world,
but especially children.
We have a really wonderful huge
body of children's literature
in the United States and as an
old retired children's librarian,
I'm really proud of that.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
>> One more I think.
>> Good morning.
Who are your-- some of your favorite
authors of the last 5 or 10 years
and what are you reading now?
>> Right now, I'm reading Cutting
for Stone by Abraham Verghese.
He was a Texas Book Festival
before with one of his books.
I don't know if he-- has been a
National Book Festival writer,
but it's terrific.
It's a great book about twins
but also about Ethiopia.
Then I read and this was one of the
books given to me by Booksellers
on my book tour, My Name is
Mary Sutter, historical fiction
about the Civil War, really
great by Robin Oliveira
and so I recommend both of those.
George is reading the new
biography about Bonhoeffer.
That's the title, Bonhoeffer.
And I can't wait to get my
hands on it and read it next.
So I'm usually reading the newest
books by Book Festival authors.
I'll be at the Texas Book
Festival in late October for the--
also and so I hope that any of you
that have a chance can also come
there for the Texas Book Festival.
Thank you all very much.
[Background applause]
I think my time is up.
I appreciate it very, very much.
Thank you all.
God bless you all.
Thanks a lot.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov